now zanine zagari ratcliffe may be one
step closer to freedom
but her return to the uk is not yet
guaranteed
the ankle tag she was ordered to wear
whilst on home leave has now been
removed
marking the end of her sentence nazzani
was jailed for five years over spying
allegations she denies
after being detained at tehran airport
but she's now been ordered back to court
in a week
over separate charges her husband
richard
at home in london with their daughter
gabriella told me the news was mixed
richard's sister rebecca spoke to us
shortly after the development
we're quite pleased that the ankle tag's
been taken off and richard just
processing that at the moment
um but you know we don't really know how
to interpret what's going to happen
uh later on this week don't know how to
interpret being summoned
next sunday is it that they're going to
just finish off all the paperwork and
release them give her passport back or
is it that they're going to whack her
with that second sentence
we don't know and i think there's a few
more sleepless nights ahead of us
sleepless nights as you say but i mean
the agony just seems to go on for you
all as a family
yeah it does i mean you've been
following this story for five years
we've been living it for five years
and at the moment there's still no end
in sight to it um
it may be in a week or two time we we
get that passport back and she's on a
plane and
fantastic but we just don't know and
this agony can go on for a lot longer as
you can imagine
with her uncle tag gone nazarene has
been able to leave her parents house in
tehran
and we understand went to visit
relatives of another dual british
national
held by the iranians but with so much
uncertainty still
surrounding her situation the foreign
secretary said iran's continued
treatment of nazanin was intolerable a
former foreign secretary said diplomatic
efforts must be stepped up
hostage diplomacy is wrong it is immoral
it is absolutely disgusting that we are
doing this
it may be now that it has come to the
situation where it has to be
dealt with at a head of government level
it may be the boris
needs to make contact with the iranian
supreme
leader and resolve the issue at that
level
richard ratcliffe shared this video with
us of a painting by nazanin
depicting their reunion they will hope
the latest bittersweet developments
take them closer to this vision becoming
a reality
lisa holland sky news
well the prime minister has added his
thoughts to the debate on twitter this
evening by saying please to see the
removal of nazanin zigari ratcliffe's
ankle tag
but her continued confinement remains
totally unacceptable
she must be released permanently so she
can return to her family in the uk
and we continue to do all we can to
achieve this